gina carano a star of disney's
star wars tv show the mandalorian has
been cancelled
she has been canceled apparently for
something that she said about the jews
which sounds really bad you know and
bigoted and everything we're going to
get into what she actually said
i don't think she said anything wrong
whatsoever but but even more broadly
if disney executives don't like what
gina carano has to say about the jews
just imagine their shock when they
google walt disney
i think i was a little unfair to walt
disney
you know walt disney there was this kind
of rumor that he hated the jews or
something he was kind of a bigot
there's actually really no evidence of
this but
i figure it's a funny enough hit same
cannot be said at baby yoda though i
can't believe they haven't canceled that
guy yet
you get a couple drinks and baby yoda
you you set him off talking about the
jews and the mexicans and the italian oh
my gosh
it's like it's like little green david
duke or something but gina carano didn't
say anything wrong
uh disney put out a statement based on
gina carano's
old social media posts you say her
social media posts denigrating people
based on their cultural and religious
identities
are abhorrent and unacceptable
oh gosh abhorrent nonexistent okay what
did she say so i pulled up the post this
is
the worst post they could find this this
is the height of her bigotry
on social media gina carano wrote
jews were beaten in the streets not by
nazi soldiers but by their neighbors
even by children because history is
edited most people don't realize
that to get to the point where nazi
soldiers could easily round up thousands
of jews the government first made their
own neighbors hate them simply for being
jews
how is that any different from hating
someone for their political views
like she's saying the nazi regime had
this hatred of jews
ethnically and religiously and so it's
not like they just came in one day and
everyone was being really nice to the
jews and then the nazis said well no
we're going to be
awful to them and round them up and you
know commit all these atrocities
no they fomented a culture in which jews
were
otherized castigated whatever term you
want to use
and gina grano's saying this can be done
politically as well this can be done to
people based on their political views
just as it can be based on their
ethnicity
or based on their religion uh
duh of course that's true there's
nothing it's not denigrating jews at all
issues denigrating nazis but that seems
perfectly fine
is the issue here for disney that gina
carano was making a
nazi comparison is disney saying you
know it's it's wrong
to invoke any sort of nazi imagery ever
when making a political point
uh fair enough but if you were to if you
were to hold that view then
most people would fall silent because
the only two historical events
most people especially leftists know
anything about is world war ii in the
fall of the roman empire right that's
all those are the only sort of events
anyone ever invokes
joe biden just did this joe biden just
compared donald trump to goebbels
like a few months ago we're not
the the left the entire left has been
calling
donald trump literally hitler and
calling 75 million americans
nazis for years
but it's it's wrong when carano she's
not even
com exactly comparing the democrats to
nazis she's just saying
that this kind of culture in which
conservatives are being ostracized and
censored and
deplored that has historical parallels
is that is that the issue here
really the reason they're doing this
because i actually thought gina carano
had already been fired
this story came up months and months ago
and it's it's not because she said
anything about the jews or because she
said anything about the nazis or because
she said anything about anybody
it's because she is a conservative and
she supports trump and she's made fun of
woke culture and so the fix was always
in they were always going to try to get
her
now they're using this ridiculous excuse
it's kind of like what they did to megyn
kelly
which is you had people on network news
who
wore blackface right you had uh
what's her joy behar darkened her skin
for a costume you had people on nbc
where megan kelly was working
who would wear blackface in sketches
totally fine but then megan kelly one
day was discussing the topic of
blackface she said you know
if you were to darken your skin to be
part of a costume to portray
an individual not a race broadly but an
individual is that okay and they fired
her for it
they call it her blackface controversy
is it
as if raising the mere topic of
blackface was so offensive
and yet for the other hosts to actually
wear it not offensive at all it's it's
because
there's no principle here it's just that
nbc didn't like megan kelly so they were
going to kick her out
people are calling this cancel culture
i wish we could retire that phrase
because i don't think it's helpful it's
obviously describing a real phenomenon
we're seeing it's where
conservatives or anyone who's not a
radical leftist
gets ostracized or fired or censored for
refusing to adhere to left-wing
orthodoxy so it's a real thing that's
happening
but a cancel culture doesn't describe it
there are plenty of people who should be
cancelled i'll give you an example just
at disney
james gunn made all those jokes about
how he wanted to have sex with children
if anybody is going to be canceled james
gunn should be the one to be cancelled
not gina carano
i'll give you a further example though
because james gunn might say well i was
kidding it was in poor taste but i'm a
comedian and so
you know you got to give me a pass mark
hamill luke skywalker
is accused of trying to coerce his son's
girlfriend who his son had knocked up
into killing the baby
so mark hamill allegedly
pressured his son's girlfriend to
kill his own grandson and there are
apparently texts and messages and all
this sort of
stuff if that is true
mark hamill should be cancelled he
should be not just fired from star wars
not just fired from disney he should be
removed from polite society he should be
ostracized
he should be shunned he should be
canceled he should not be invited
to participate in things it's a very
very bad thing
he certainly should not be invited to
participate in things until he repents
and says he's sorry
and acknowledges how awful that is
because nobody seriously opposes
this broad definition of cancel culture
nobody seriously believes
that there ought to be no consequences
whatsoever
for things that people say and do nobody
believes if gina carano had walked onto
the set one day
and said zig heil heil hitler and had an
uh swastika on her clothing nobody
believes she should keep her
job what people are when they when
people oppose cancel culture what
they're saying is
that it not that there should not be
standards by which people
rise and fall in their careers but
rather
that the standards that people are being
judged by are ridiculous
because in the olden days you would be
judged by traditional standards if you
violate the traditional moral order
or traditional social mores you would
face consequences
but now it's completely upended
standards it's left-wing standards
and that's the real problem but let's
let's not overstate our case let's not
say
we're free speech purists what does that
mean there's never been such a thing as
free speech
purism there have always been categories
of speech
that are not permitted in society and
sort of behaviors that are not permitted
what we are saying we're actually saying
something a little harder i think
conservatives think it's really
simple it's easy it's inoffensive to
just say
we support all speech we support all
actions we don't want any standards it's
really easy this is why we've lost on
political correctness
we need to say something that requires
more courage we need to say some things
are right
some things are wrong you should be
permitted to say and do some things
and you should face consequences for
saying and doing other things
we have to be willing to do that it that
kind of a regime of speech and behavior
is going to exist it has in every
society and always will
it's just right now we've completely
seated that ground to the left
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you